in Industries where there aren't people
that look like you
go where you don't belong because one
day you will
when we started our business we
definitely were faced with extra
challenges some biases we had a lot of
pushback as to whether or not black
women actually even drank wine or if
black women could run a wine business of
course all of that sort of fueled our
passion and our mission and really
working to serve this this consumer that
we felt we know so well and deserve to
be represented
[Music]
I think we have to start with us as the
story yes both of us were born in Los
Angeles to the same father we grew up
thinking that we were only children on
completely different sides of the world
and different hemispheres I grew up in
Central Coast of California in Monterey
she grew up in New Zealand and even
though we were a world apart we both
grew up in really beautiful agricultural
areas we both longed to be wine makers
and we both actually longed to have a
sibling we reunited in 1999 when I got
the letter and found out that I had a
little sister and I was like this really
sounds very scammy but I of course
called a number that was on the letter
and we actually made plans to meet the
next day it changed my life forever I
just can't imagine life without her now
so
17 years later we have a multinational
wine company and we have a
non-for-profit the McBride sisters she
can fund
we have three brands McBride sisters
collection wines which are our wines
from where I grew up in Central Coast of
California and in New Zealand where
Andre grew up we have black girl magic
wines which are premium wines from
California and we have chican wines
which of course is our Wines in a can
she can wines we launched in 2019 we
wanted to take that opportunity to give
back we've seen a lot of the struggles
that women were having in the industry
so we started our professional
Development Fund which would be
scholarships mentorships grants for
professional women and wine and spirits
2020 was a little bit of a different
year the pandemic was starting to take a
hold of the world we started to see some
really disturbing numbers around the
federal funding the TPP grants that were
going to businesses we started to learn
that black owned businesses won were
shuttering at a much faster rate than
any other and that 96 percent of the
businesses either didn't qualify or were
rejected for the PVP funding and we
decided that year that we were going to
award cash grants to Black women-owned
businesses and then we had some amazing
support from corporate donors as well
that also were able to provide
Professional Services to these
businesses assistants with financial
planning HR and employee management that
some of these businesses might need in
such a challenging time the swine label
is called Papa to anuku which in Maori
translates to Mother Earth Pinot Noir is
a very fickle hard grape to grow it has
thinner skin and really expresses the
dirt in which it's grown the Wayne
industry has had some version of wine
education but it's been pretty dull
this is my favorite one you tried to
create something that would engage folks
in a new way and help them remember what
they were learning super soaky soft
tenants it just like coats your whole
mouth it has a really long finish and
like there's really good integration of
flavor traditionally wine and food
pairings have been from this quite
eurocentric standpoint that comfy and
Chardonnay and we integrated pop culture
we integrated contemporary ways in which
people would like to eat and drink we
were talking about what goes with tacos
we're talking about wine and watch what
are you watching on Netflix and what
should you pair with
Innovation really comes and growth
really comes from diversity of thought
so if you have people from all different
walks of life and backgrounds it doesn't
matter what the problem is that
everybody's going to approach to intro
and solve it in a different way and
that's when the breakthroughs happen and
so I think because the wine industry
hasn't been that diverse there is so
much opportunity and so we're actually
really optimistic and excited about the
future
I think success for me will be when this
industry fully represents the world
around us yes that it's not dominated by
one gender or One race of people that it
really is representing the consumer more
people love wine than ever before so
when I can visually see that when we go
out in the world and that's who's at our
industry conferences and who's at the
winemakers conferences I'll feel that
that's that success yeah
foreign